Yeah, yeah.
No, no.
No, no, no, no, no.
Oh, no, no, no!
Oh!
(announcer)
Mission failed.
You suck.
Oh, you're so close.
That was close.
Okay, I want to try,
what do I need to know?
Yeah, yeah, okay, well,
just let me switch my character
'cause you will
ruin my rating.
There we go.
Now, it's just like
"Call of Duty,"
except the gameplay
is way more realistic, so.
Oh, cool,
I can be a girl.
Yeah.
Knock yourself out.
I'm gonna grab us beers.
Oh, she's cute.
(man)
Listen up, soldiers.
We've received intel
that there are insurgents
hiding in that village.
Let's go.
Wait,
why am I not moving?
You hang back, private.
What...
♪
(controller clicking)
Wait, what--
What the (bleep), no.
(sighs)
No--
What are you doing
hanging out in the barrack
all by yourself, lazy?
No, I--
I think--
I think my character
was just raped.
No.
No, no, no, no, no.
Yeah.
That's never happened to me,
you must have pressed
the wrong button.
That's not part of the game.
Ted, trust me,
it happened.
No.
(announcer)
You were just assaulted
by a fellow soldier.
Do you wish to report?
Yeah.
Weird.
Uh-huh.
What is this?
You know what?
Let me go check
the message boards.
Yes, I wish to report it.
(announcer)
Are you sure?
Yes, I'm sure.
Did you know he has a family?
No.
Does that change your mind
about reporting?
No.
What?
Level 25 unlocked.
My God.
It's just like
a ton of paperwork.
♪
Okay.
This is great.
Have you seen this picture
of the big, fat Japanese baby?
You're supposed to be checking
the message boards.
Oh, yeah, yeah,
yeah, yeah, yeah.
But you gotta see
that picture later.
(announcer)
Paperwork complete.
Welcome to the Pentagon,
soldier.
Good luck!
Ooh, the Pentagon.
Watch out, they're attacking
your character.
There isn't even
anyone around me.
(man 2)
What were you wearing?
Be a team player.
Occupational hazard.
You got to go along
to get along.
(announcer)
Character
assassination complete.
Attention, soldier.
Your attacker was found guilty
in a military court.
Yes, finally,
thank you.
But his commanding officer
chose to reject that decision,
so he is now back
on active duty.
What?!
They can do that?
What the (bleep) is this game?
(bleep) your (bleep) stupid
military bull (bleep)!
Hey, hey, hey, hey,
language, language.
Be a lady.
This is insane.
Why would anyone
want to play this?
Look it.
I checked the message boards
and it doesn't say anything,
so obviously you did
something wrong.
It's probably best
you don't play, okay?
(video game music)
Here we go.
(mimics gunfire)
Why are you
making that noise?
It helps.
(mimics gunfire)